[Music]
because our lecture today prides himself
in his trove of interesting jokes and
stories I decided I'd better start off
with a joke jack and it's one that does
have relevance to deduction in the
scientific method and it has to do with
Sherlock Holmes and dr. Watson being out
on a camping trip they were lying there
in their sleeping bags in the middle of
the night on their backs looking up at
the heavens and crystal clear night and
millions and millions of stars across
the sky and Holmes turned and said I say
Watson what do you make of all this what
do you think about when you see all
these stars what do you deduce from it
Watson thought a bit and said well my
friend I think it's a message to us it's
there to remind us of the vastness of
the universe and the miracle of its
creation and to clearly send the signal
to us that of all those billions of
stars out there as far as we know we're
the only planet with intelligent people
on what a special place we hold said
what do you make of it Holmes Holmes
said well Watson I deduce that someone
has stolen our tent so with that as the
15th president of MIT it's my pleasure
to welcome you to the first of three
Karl Taylor Compton lectures that will
be given during 1998-99 this lecture
series was established in 1957 to honor
the institute's 9th president dr.
Compton held that post from 1930 to 1948
and went on to serve as chairman of the
MIT corporation from 1948 until his
death in 1954
in his quarter century of service to MIT
Katy Compton led a crucial expansion and
modernization of our institution in
words of one of his contemporaries he
was instrumental in transforming MIT
quote from a good but more or less
provincial Institute to an international
institution at the same time he provided
extraordinary leadership in bringing
science and technology to the service of
our nation during the Great Depression
during World War two and in the critical
early years of the Cold War he served in
a variety of senior governmental
positions including chairmanship of the
depression-era Science Advisory Board
chief of the wartime radar programs of
the Office of scientific research and
development and the first head of the
research and development board that was
created by President Truman to oversee
scientific preparedness in the years
after World War two these lectures were
created as a fitting memorial to Karl
Taylor Compton 's ability to bring the
innovations the values and the wisdom of
science technology and academic inquiry
into the arena's of Public Policy and
popular discourse the purpose of the
series is to give the MIT community an
opportunity to hear from meet with key
leaders who are helping to shape and
inform global events sponsored each time
by a different academic department the
Compton lectures have brought a
distinguished array of global leaders to
our campus past Compton lectures have
included statesmen like Hubert Humphrey
former Japanese Prime Minister NACA Sony
and they've included Nobel laureates
such as Niels Bohr and Linus Pauling
indeed last year's lecture was both a
statesman and a Nobel laureate dr. Oscar
Arias Sanchez of Costa Rica
this year's Compton lectures are
sponsored by the political science
department in conjunction with the
Office of the Provost they have brought
us a speaker who is well qualified to
carry on in the tradition of his
distinguished predecessors Dido would be
difficult to find someone who better
Mises Katy Compton's own devotion to the
development of science and technology as
instruments of national service in the
public interest
Jack Gibbons is an internationally
recognized scientific leader whose early
career specialty was nuclear physics
after earning his doctorate at Duke he
spent 15 years as a researcher at the
Oak Ridge National Laboratory beginning
in 1970 his professional focus began to
shift and he undertook pioneering work
on the use of technology in conserving
energy as well as in minimizing adverse
environmental impacts from energy
production and consumption at the start
of the nation's first major energy
crisis in 1973 jack was therefore
well-positioned to become the first
director of the federal office of energy
conservation after two years in that
post he returned to Tennessee as head of
the University of Tennessee's energy
environment and resources center in 79
he was called back to Washington to
direct the office of Technology
Assessment the OTA an independent
professional agency that provides
Congress provided Congress with
nonpartisan expert analysis on a wide
variety of issues involving science
technology and public policy after two
six-year terms as head of OTA Jack was
selected by President Clinton to be the
assistant to the president for science
and technology and director of the
Office of Science and Technology Policy
job he performed with great distinction
until he decided to step down early this
calendar year in his role as the
president's science advisor as in so
much of his career Jack Gibbons has been
a forceful and effective advocate for
the importance of understanding and
using science and technology in programs
and policies designed to address larger
public issues several of us from here at
MIT myself included greatly enjoyed the
pleasure of working directly with Jack
through our joint service on the
Committee of Advisors and Science and
Technology through that closed
professional Association we have come to
appreciate that jack is exactly the kind
of scientist that president Compton
found so valuable and virtuous his
leader not only in his own field but in
the complex and demanding business of
bringing science and technology into the
mainstream of public discourse and
policymaking Jack's most recent book is
entitled this gifted age science and
technology at the millennium his lecture
for today is entitled the 21st century
will Science and Technology contribute
to society or scuttle it his second
lecture which will be delivered here at
the same time on Monday November 30th
bears an equally provocative title
governance of Science and Technology
theory myths and reality I think I know
how he will answer the question in the
title of this day's lecture I have no
idea what he will say in November but
please join me in welcoming an
outstanding colleague and good friend
Jack Givens
I think I have my mic on is that right
good president vest how indeed nice it
is to be with you and to come to MIT in
this capacity I'm greatly honored by the
invitation and I look forward to the
weeks and months ahead and working with
individuals and departments and programs
as well as these several Compton
lectures I want to especially thank
Chuck vest for taking the time to
introduce me he doesn't have very much
to do of course as you understand as
Chuck when he came to MIT was also very
very generous in his time with a lot of
issues we had to deal with in Washington
and I don't know whether his wife has
forgiven me yet but I remember in one
occasion in which he was helping try to
figure out what in the world to deal
with the space station back in 1993 and
I think his last night on that project
he saw he worked not only through the
night but saw the dawn and Sun come up
the next morning while he was still
trying to finish that work up for the
president I think that's first time that
had happened to him since graduate
school but I want to in case you don't
know I want to congratulate Chuck in
public for the fact that he's now
grandfather
you don't look at Chuck but we're very
proud and happy for you and for aunt
Rebecca it's no accident my coming to
MIT I learned to come to the place that
I saw as the as a symbol of the front
edge of higher education and research
and public service in terms of Science
and Technology in our nation's future
there's no question in my mind what MIT
carries the leading flag in that regard
and I'm therefore a little bit of about
feel a little bit like carrying coals to
Newcastle to talk with you about these
issues but nonetheless bear with me and
you can attack me when I finish my gonna
finish my lecture I do in this first
lecture want to say that I'm drawing on
not only my past work at OTA and and the
office of science and technology policy
but also to a degree my prior
experiences in research and in
technology development the course now
I'm out of government and have changed
my pace and I'm my office is now on the
farm
in Northern Virginia a comfortable hour
away from downtown Washington and in
setting up shop in at home I had to get
a computer setup and a lot of other
things going on so I got some advice
called the farmers guide to computers
and there are several definitions I
thought I would share with you to log on
means making the woodstove hauteur
monitor means keeping an eye on the
woodstove download means getting the
firewood off the pickup truck a floppy
disk means what you get from pollen too
much firewood up and windows means what
to shut when it's 30 degrees outside and
finally mainframe is what holds up the
barn roof so if you have to remember to
get your term straight even though the
words may be identically the meanings
are different in one setting versus
another but thank you so much for
inviting you to be with you on the
enduring this 1998-99 winter season the
title I conjured up for the talk is a
teaser you know it it's not either/or
it's always both Robert Louis Stevenson
said that nature never gives anything to
anyone everything is sold at a price it
is only in the ideals of abstraction
that choice comes without consequence
alvin weinberg talked about nuclear
energy in terms of the Faustian bargain
and if you want to take the powerful
opportunities of nuclear energy you also
have to make the bargain of of
stewardship and because technology is
the human use or application of
knowledge and because humanity always
displays the passion for both good and
evil there's no question but what
powerful technology will add either to
the benefit of humankind or to its
detriment depending on how humans use it
and in thinking about the this question
of the 21st century and the role of
Technology
I had a few images flashed across my
minds first of all National Defense
these days is certainly governed by the
fact that we have the science and
technology edge that we have obtained
since World War two it is an enormous
asset for us in terms of providing an
assured national security at a much
lower investment of people and money
than otherwise would be required by
virtue of having front of the edge
technology the food we eat the drink we
drink the shelter over our heads the
interior lights and illumination the
illumination and the heating and cooling
all of these things are direct results
of technology that would have been the
envy of King Croesus disease these days
is not exactly on the retreat but we're
certainly gaining in terms of the
ultimate goal of as one physician
described to me once having people turn
into alkaline batteries you know an
alkaline battery runs and runs and runs
until it just suddenly dies instead of
petering out like a carbon-based battery
and he said that's our objective for
Humanity we should make turn people into
alkaline batteries and I think we're
doing a pretty good job of it given the
extension of useful active healthy lives
that come about by virtue of Technology
and medicine job increase has been
enormous because of the opportunities
provided by advancing technology for
people to use them themselves in very
productive ways transportation is beyond
belief of my father even much less my
grandfather communication and access to
knowledge is beyond the belief of people
who only thought about
this only 20 years ago before internet
had its explosion and the opportunities
now in this latter day succession to the
invention of the printing press to have
access to knowledge from whence cometh
power and influence environmental wastes
is another area where we have made
extraordinary gains let me give you an
example this first slide I took from a
magazine some years back I think it was
advertising sewer treatment but can you
imagine our cities today without the
capability that technology provides for
gathering and assimilating and treating
wastes that otherwise would make urban
living simply impossible the convenience
and amenities provided by technology are
essentially too numerous to mention
and I think Oliver Wendell Holmes
captured the the positive spirit of
Science and Technology when he wrote the
following Holmes wrote true science
knows no bounds it penetrates into every
domain without fear and it serves all
men without prejudice or favor it's work
is to substitute facts for appearances
demonstrations for impressions and
beneficial realities for those many
things that ignorance and greed proclaim
to be impossible for suffering humanity
says Holmes it is hope and promise now I
could spend all day talking about the
goods but as Ken bowling always said you
should also talk about the Bad's because
that's the other side of the coin and in
my thinking about today's talk and where
we are now I thought about just several
things that I think we should be we
should admit to first of all that
technology has led to the proliferation
of weapons of mass destruction in a form
and scale never before what
on the face of the earth both nuclear
and chemical weapons and their use not
only by nation states but also by small
terrorist groups now makes the world a
very different place and security a very
different thing from what it was a scant
several decades ago population growth
has been extraordinary driven by the
fact that health has brought death to
death controlled downward and birth
rates remained high and the consequence
of the difference between those two
functions led to a very rapid increase
in world population for example when DDT
after post World War two was introduced
into Sri Lanka death rates felled by a
factor of two very suddenly and the
population of sri lanka doubled in 17
years
this is a a benefit of death control but
the discipline of it of having a sudden
imbalance between two things that only
slowly slowly change and it's not just
numbers it's an issue of quality of life
that goes with population and this is
another ad from a in this case a
newspaper who wants to go to Jamaica
when you've got the in the summer when
you have the beach right here well these
are people and I think the ocean starts
about here but you can see the problem
illustrated by this name that we have in
terms of quiet empty spaces for those
uniquely human functions of population
in in many ways is already out stripping
our resources see how this works I'm
gonna run back over to the podium
along with the population explosion and
the press-on people comes also a loss of
privacy that has is it is a child of
some of our modern technology derived
through information technologies
expansion and such things as DNA typing
which now give us a different and
additional reasons to have to apply
governance to the use of these
technologies in order to assure
traditional freedoms of a choice and of
privacy if this is going to be a matter
of continuing an increasing concern if
we want the benefits of advances in
information technology and molecular
biology we also must along with that
join with public policies that help
assure our traditional freedoms that are
that can be infringed by the misuse of
that kind of technology our
environmental losses have been large we
have lost some species at an increasing
rate the Chesapeake Bay oyster yield is
now 1% of what it was 100 years ago
zebra mussels now cost us nearly 7
billion dollars a year in management
cost in the US alone we are doing things
with our atmosphere on a global scale
that I will return to in a few minutes
in other words we have some Bad's that
come along with the goods and we have
rising conflicts between technology and
and its use on the one hand and
traditional ethical and religious and
cultural values this is perhaps
personified by the great writer and
anthropologist Loren eiseley who made
this exclamation in his book on book
called the firmament of time Eisley I
think personified the frustration that a
lot of people have about technology and
it's kind of tough to read but I think
it's important for the those of us in
technology to understand this feeling
Eisley says it is with the coming of man
that a vast hole seems to open up in
a vast black whirlpool spinning faster
and faster consuming flesh stones soil
minerals sucking down the lightning
wrenching power from the atom until the
ancient sounds of nature are drowned in
a cacophony of something that is no
longer nature something instead which is
loose and knocking at the world's heart
something demonic and no longer planned
escaped
it may be spewed out of nature
contending in a final Giants game
against its master those are tough words
from I sleep but I think they very
poignant Lee point out the frustration
that many people have about the way
things are moving under the influence of
advancing technology Pope most recently
Pope Paul just this month on the
twentieth anniversary of our lyrics in
cyclic OH warns about Science and
Technology progress as putting humanity
at risk and I think that while that's
true that's but one side of the coin and
I'm afraid that it's up to us to make
sure people understand that with every
powerful idea including Technology one
has the power both for good and evil so
what lessons do I draw from this litany
first of all the power of free and open
society of open markets and cede ground
for innovation such as we find in our
country provides for efficiency it is a
there is a concomitant need though to
manage externalities and to assure level
playing fields but there is an enormous
power never before witnessed in terms of
creativity and its influence on the way
people live and their options and
opportunities that derive from
technology the second observation is or
lesson is that the power of that science
and technology have to provide brand-new
options to do things to achieve goals to
provide for our wants and needs both the
goods and the bads but you can't have
one without the other
the third observation is this
extraordinarily pervasive and growing
dependence that humanity has on science
and technology for its livelihood in its
future force the stress is imposed on
societies and social institutions by the
high and even accelerating rates of
change driven of course by Science and
Technology change and the results of
this can be seen in so many ways
the rise of neoconservatism of
creationism a lot of other as it were
retreats I think our outward examples of
the concern people have about this
almost intolerable rate of change that
they seem to see being imposed upon
their traditional thoughts and values
and finally in terms of observations
from this litany of the recent past in
general I think the dynamics of
exponential expansion ISM are catching
up with us
the exponential has been for a long time
been the surrogate for progress as long
as we can grow things can get better
girl-- measured by way of the extent to
which we consume raw materials I reserve
the word growth I'd rather call it
expansionism because growth can mean a
lot of different things to different
people but this 20th century paradigm of
growth through expansionism of the
exponential being our salvation I think
is now anachronistic Robert Hale Bruner
who is a I guess combined sociologist
and economist Chuck if I remember right
wrote recently that the coming
generation he said will be the last
generation to seize control over
technology before technology ceases
irreversibly seizes control over it a
generation is not much time he says but
it is some time and that's pretty
serious business to say that somehow
technology as and as an external force
somehow from
Society has that kind of capacity and
power and I think it confuses technology
on the one hand from ourselves on the
other and I think we need to we need to
concentrate and understand though the
feeling that arises in people who would
who would make statements like that well
what about the 21st century that's what
I came here to talk about but you can't
look ahead without looking back a little
bit and I would make several
observations about the 21st century
first of all I don't think there's any
end in sight for discovery or the
development of new options every day
tells us that we're still if anything on
an accelerating pace of discovery Louis
Thomas said before he died that he
thought the greatest history would show
that the greatest discovery of the 20th
century was the discovery of the extent
of human ignorance and I think that may
well carry over to the 21st century but
it's Ernie with his an apt statement
about the extent to which knowledge is
costing and unfolding phenomenon this
and that will happen right straight on
into the next century the second thing I
would say is that our economic market
basket is growing and will continue to
grow but that the contents of the market
basket are and will be shifting
depending on how we go about providing
goods and services and and for the
people's wants there is no apparent
limit as far as I can tell to greed or
avarice that seems to be in our genes
somehow but there is indeed some hope
and some evidence that we're beginning
to think more carefully about what we
mean by growth and progress for example
one statement that is very appealing to
me is that there's a big difference
between being rich and being wealthy of
being rich on the one hand is making
lots of money being wealthy is having
lots of time and I think that notion of
trade-off between money and other Desiro
is something that we may well want to
pay more attention to in the coming
century and maybe technology will help
us get there third statement about the
21st century
is that our global problems are indeed
looming up on us
and I think it will be a century in
which we will have to become constantly
and evermore carefully thinking in
global terms and linking our globe our
local actions to global actions and our
actions now to events and actions in the
future population is is growing we hope
that the 21st century will exhibit a
leveling off or at least a tendency in
that direction of global population we
know our atmosphere is becoming markedly
changed by human activities and I'll
return to that in a few minutes and we
know that our biosphere is being
significantly impacted globally by human
activities in terms of diversity and
depletion of species and the loss of
habitats as a consequence of some of
these as well as other things social
stresses are indeed amplified and as I
said before religious fundamentalism
economic frustration emerges from these
kinds of stresses and can result in a
violent conflict and in terms of global
problems deadly conflict and terrorism
is certainly not new in the world but it
is more intense and more deadly with the
modern technology there is indeed no
hiding-place now anywhere over the globe
from this kind of frustration exhibiting
itself in terrorism so just as economics
are now globally globally tied and
integrated so too is Environment and
security now the thing that strikes me
is that many of the biggest challenges
presented to us population climate
change biodiversity have large
hysteresis in them and they are
conflicts they present conflicts of the
time constants involved in other words
they seem to develop fairly slowly as
measured in terms of political response
and and the nd and the attention gotten
by the the public and at the same time
many of them are nearly irreversible or
you
completely irreversible in the future so
there's not not a symmetric oncoming and
outgoing there is a there is a
hysteresis in that process and that
presents some real problems Adlai
Stevenson once observed that American
people never seemed to see the hand
white writing on the wall until their
back is up against it and I think it's
probably a truism it's not just American
people it's generally people have that
feeling the closer to them personally or
in their backyard and the more attention
it gets and global biodiversity changed
global climate change are not things
that at least superficially present a
lot of handwriting on the wall until our
back is up against it and Mario Molina
or knows all of a hi Mario knows all
about that and the question is how can
you take such an enormous ly important
thing in the planetary Commons and
transform it from a never Neverland way
down the road therefore I'll forget
about it too an issue that that is
perceived and interpreted as something
of immediate concern to us immediate
self in terminal self-interest concern
most of these issues live outside the
traditional marketplace they are indeed
the so called global Commons and the
problem is that we are now treading on
the global Commons to the point that
it's not a free good anymore as we used
to think I remember when I was a kid
Chuck I'm older than you are but I
remember when I was a kid people would
say what do you mean it's a free country
and free country meant in those days
it's a linear country you know if you if
you get into trouble you just need to
move a little bit farther away from your
neighbor it had no sense of that kind of
interconnectedness or non-linearity that
now is reality for all of us well what's
the point the point is I think that with
sufficient lead time and I would proffer
this with sufficient lead time most if
not many if not most of these issues
that I've spoken about can be addressed
using ingenuity with science and
technology but we need the political
will to do so
need to catalyze a political or public
will to take to take action on issues
before the hand before our back is up
against the wall there are some
successful lessons I think you all know
about stratospheric ozone as a good
recent example of a successful lesson in
this regard in which between Mario and
some other people they finally
understood what was happening in the
atmosphere and we're concerned about
certain man-made chemicals affecting
these the thickness of the stratospheric
ozone layer which in turn protects life
on the earth from from ultraviolet rays
from the Sun and people began to worry
about how what other kind of chemicals
could be used for refrigerants and the
likes that didn't have this unhappy
property and so they began working along
and and the chemists came up with some
wonderful technology substitutes for
these these these unhappy these
molecules that that are triggering the
the destruction of stratospheric ozone
industry understood that this was a
market opportunity and that they could
substitute one for another in fact there
were some substitutes for the
chlorofluorocarbons that were cheaper
and more effective than the
chlorofluorocarbons and just as we were
trying to form a public policy to
collectively have all the world's
nations work on getting this
stratospheric ozone protection up along
came the observations of these enormous
holes in the ozone in the antarctic and
the explanation related back to human
activities and to me it's still a wonder
because I've been to the South Pole to
look up into the heavens whether it be
in Boston or in McMurdo Sound and see
this enormous atmosphere up there and
know that is being a materially affected
specifically by human activities for the
first time since since humanity came
about but it's a good example of where
we did as a world of nations find a
technical alternative Institute some
price changes which pushed the market in
the right direction and put in place a
process whereby within a
about fifty years thirty to fifty years
we will find the ozone depletion
dropping off and moving back to or
greater protection but mind you it'll
take about a half a century before we
really see significant improvements in
that in that erosion a long time
constant another is the the Clean Air
Act which as you know was passed with
the great trepidation because there was
concern about the cost of cleaning up
the air the estimates turned out to be
about 10 times more costly than the
actual facts of the matter now why did
the facts of the matter have end up
being so much less costly and cleaning
up the air two reasons one was
innovative technology and the second was
to institute trading of clean air rights
so that those who could clean up the air
least accost lee were able to sell their
capabilities to those that were mid
emitting pollutants but but it was too
expensive to clean them up so by trading
these emission rights where they were
able to go the minimum cost path for the
improvement in air pollution and we
ended up with about 10 percent of the
original cost estimate to do the job
that was needed we're going to need some
more of that in the future but it's
another good example where collective
action can work well what about the
future then CP snow once said
incidentally that a sense of the future
and that's what we're here today to talk
about a sense of the future is behind
all good politics unless one can have it
one can leave nothing either wise or
decent to the world it's really
incumbent on us to have the commitment
to think about the future not to know
where it's going but have a sense of
where it may be going depending on the
actions we take between now and then as
Al Gore what has frequently said the
thing about doing for the future is to
do it smart to not do it dumb and we
know ourselves that we've done some dumb
things in the past and we hope that we
don't repeat those in the future and
that we can pass on some of those
lessons to the third world
doing things smart means using elegant
and thoughtful technology some of those
examples I would like to mention to you
one is the term some sometimes called
green manufacturing others industrial
ecology it's a very simple thing in
principle elegant in practice and making
its way now especially in Europe but
also in the United States and the and
other other advanced industrial
countries the old method is to simply
take a linear flow of materials and
products and waste streams and the newer
notion is to integrate all the way
across from the initial design of a
product to its ultimate disposition and
use of the materials and in doing so
make a materials choice at the design in
that's going to make the tail end of the
system work a lot better in other words
put a bubble around the entire
production process rather than segregate
these off into different parts a good
lesson early to me in Tennessee was cold
strip mining where the mining people
used to just strip off the the dirt dump
it down the hill mine the coal and and
then either leave or come back maybe and
push some of the dirt back that was very
expensive and not very effective because
they separated the recovery or
restoration process from the mining
process as though there were two
different things then they began to
realize that if they would integrate
these two processes together and make
recovery a part and parcel of the mining
process they could do a more effective
job and that's what's caused now the
ability with full integration of wrath
of the recover the ultimate recovery and
use of the land an integral part of the
mining process and it has resolved a lot
of problems in in the coal fields the
same generally in manufacturing I think
is a very important idea for B going to
be going in and we're making some good
strides a second is in the
transportation sector as an example we
now have
even though petroleum prices are lower
than they've ever been we are making
good progress on being able to use fuels
for transportation for instance in
automobiles that perhaps three times the
efficiency of present automobiles with
the same degree of comfort and safety
and attractiveness and this is a has so
many public benefits as well as private
benefits that there is a consortium of
government and industry working together
over a 10-year period to push the
technologies ahead to the point that
this can be a practical reality a
substitution therefore of elegant
technology for what we used to have in
the past as a consequence of that kind
of work
you can devise this the following sort
of future scenario this is time versus
millions of barrels per day of oil for
the United States and the green is
domestic production the red is net
imports and the yellow line at the very
top of the envelope is future demand for
patrol domestic demand for petroleum in
the in the transportation sector and you
see if you introduce overtime improved
technologies for simply for more
efficient use of energy and also for
alternative and so and supplementary
fuels you see what can happen you can
move from our domestic oil production
upward by additional fuels from Alaska
plus some alternative fuels for example
from biomass and others other domestic
sources this cuts into the net imports
from the bottom and then one can lay in
different scenarios of introducing
efficient automobiles and trucks into
the fleets so that the energy demand
drops even though the expansion of
transportation continues this means one
can move from an envelope of domestic
consumption like this and very large
imports down to a point that we could
have imports that would be at almost a
level amout by the time we get to
between 2010 and 2020 which may well be
a very important
time because that's the time in which
the demand from the emerging nations
India China others will be having a much
greater call on global petroleum
availability and this will help ease the
pressure on global availability of
petroleum the an example therefore of
long-term capital stock turnover where
the property of the capital stock is for
is to provide that good or service with
less energy-intensive 'no set in the
21st century is the undoubted question
of how we move toward the next cycle of
primary energy availability in the globe
these are cycles historic up to here of
the dominance of wood and then coal and
then oil and now very shortly natural
gas and that pattern continues on to
about the middle of the coming century
in during which nuclear and other
advanced forms of energy are going to
undoubtedly have to begin to make their
play in the market and how that divides
out between different energy sources or
i call it energy sorcery depends a lot
on where technology takes us in the
interim but it's going to be an
interesting half-century incidentally
historical context
look what's been happening to the carbon
intensive nosov energy this is a global
plot it goes from the point eight five
down to about 0.55 between 1850 and the
year 2000 as a result of that
substitution of moving from coal to
petroleum to natural gas
so the carbon intensive nasaw our energy
system has indeed been changing quite
steadily and that's to our credit and it
we have more to go but it's going to get
tougher as we move on out into the 21st
century
in biotech we have an enormous
opportunity this May as the president
said this may be that the century for
the life sciences where the 20th 20th
century was a century for the physical
sciences
I can't separate them out that well
myself as as Harold Varmus said medicine
would be almost nowhere now if it
weren't for crystallography and x-rays
and all sorts of fancy physical
techniques to in order to do research
and to carry out medical procedures but
at an age of science and biotechnology
in terms of its impact on health
including its any more effective means
for birth control especially for the
developing countries and biotech for
food production will be enormous
important and I think a challenge is
full of opportunity for the coming
century in a sense it'll be a molecular
level of succession to the Green
Revolution you know in our food sector
if we do it right and do it carefully in
information technology and its impact on
education and learning on worker
productivity on efficient use of
resources including energy and materials
enormous opportunities still lie ahead
of us as we move more deeply into the
age of of information and it's very
difficult as you know to predict where
things are going to go when when things
are changing still so very very rapidly
but that just simply tells you the
opportunity is there
both upside and downside and finally in
weapons I have to say that the the
opportunity for now for the
sequestration of nuclear weapons
materials has never been greater things
are happening pretty rapidly now but we
can ill afford to wait or slow down the
disposal of plutonium is a challenge but
a lot of opportunities for doing things
if we set our minds to it the use of
technologies for effective national
technical means of verification and
monitoring are very important as nations
who don't necessarily trust each other
learn how to work with each other in
terms of being comfortable about what
the other country is doing that all
depends very deeply on technology
development and the use of existing
technology and there are some downsides
I'll give you four quick examples the
one downside is proliferation of all
sorts of weapons and methods for doing
ill it does go beyond nation-states to
individuals and on top of this I'm
frankly personally very concerned about
the talk of weaponization of space that
simply would open up in the name of
somehow building a magic shield over our
heads which won't work a way to spend a
whole lot of money as we did in the 80s
for naught and we simply can't afford
those kinds of spare resources but mark
my word I think there's going to be a
big fight in this coming decade in terms
of understanding the cost of that
impossible dream of building somehow a
shield over continental America that
will put in space the same thing we used
to have for the oceans
it's an essentially an isolationist
concept that I'm very much concerned
about not about battlefield protection
ground-based protection against missiles
but about continental wide area
protection fast way to spend money I
almost lost my job at OTA when I fought
the space-based weapons back in their
dirty reagan years so I know what of I
speak and I think another downside is
the further loss of privacy
the further inroads to the notion of
intellectual property the all of the
other downside potentials of this
extraordinarily powerful information
technology that is our going to be our
salvation and yet at the same time
something that will require careful
thought on the governance of this
extraordinary development but the slow
the slowly changing things worry me even
more
let me speak just for a few minutes
about two of them first of all
I want to speak a little bit about
population now I think most of you know
about some demographics and and the
so-called demographic charts of age
distributions this is a male and female
to the right and left of of zero lines
simply to show a nearly symmetric
function and if you look at the United
States this is about what it looked like
about five years ago it hasn't changed
that much namely we have a bulge of
population in the 20 to 40 well that's
most of you in here you are in the bulge
and that's partly due to the baby boom
and the large number of children being
born in post-war where were to Iran
beyond and then as a move back toward a
replacement rate fertility rate and of
course as this bulge moves toward the
later years you run into a lot of
problems of social security of jobs of
working people versus retired people a
lot of very important sociological
implications of a transient nature of
moving from a expanding population to
one that is static dynamic or static now
if you look at Italy it's almost a
vertical line it's almost distribution
straight from from all to very young if
you go and look at say our neighbor in
Mexico you find this kind of age
distribution enormous number of young
people with very few of the very old
people which makes should make these
folks feel better because they have all
the young folks to help take care of
when they're old right but that can't go
on forever because that produces a kind
of a population growth that's simply not
sustainable and China has has gone from
this now to try to move toward a stable
a population and they have that problem
of the Bulge and if you try to move that
bulge too quickly by decreasing birth
rates over time then you find it you
have too few young people entering the
labor market
many old people so this thing can't
change fast it takes a century or two to
make a major shift in the population
profile of our countries it's the kind
of insidious slow-moving thing that
unless you think about it carefully and
plan for it over the long term you can
get into a lot of trouble I'll show you
an example because not doing anything is
is in itself a very bad idea here is
south of southern Africa South Sahel
Africa and this is this is not these are
not data these are projections based on
population in nineteen eighty of about a
half a billion people with three
different scenarios namely that the
growth rate the fertility rate moves
from present relatively high numbers to
replacement level in this case by the
year 2030 alternatively to postpone it
and have it hip replacement level and
then stay there at about twenty forty
five versus waiting until about twenty
sixty five until it gets to replace to
the replacement level and and from that
point outward the same now a resulting
population from waiting thirty years
versus fifty years versus seventy years
is an ultimate population that's that is
but changes from a little over one and a
half billion people to about four and a
half billion people so waiting the extra
time essentially more than triples the
population of South Africa and it seems
me that's that's known as the sort of
the momentum of population and the time
delays between fertility of stability as
it were an ultimate population that the
run out of population and if we think if
if we think that Africa is going to be
better off with four and a half billion
people instead of about 1 billion people
then we're thinking of wrongly an abject
lesson in the
in the reality of the numbers was it was
it Bertram Russell that said man would
rather commit suicide than learn
arithmetic and I think you know getting
a feeling of the arithmetic on these
things is going to be very important for
us as we go into the 21st century
because is that can you see that okay
this is population and development the
I'm sorry it's so faded I'm not very
good at making color graphics yet you
see I'm no longer at white house this is
a developing developed countries and you
see by about the year 2000 it's more or
less a level number here this is the so
called developing regions of the world
and you see what's happening since 1950
and the the optimistic projection by the
United Nations is that somehow almost as
if by magic after the year 2000 we're
going to suddenly change our mind and
start leveling out population I will
believe it when it happens I hope it
does happen with I think the help of
advanced family family planning and
healthcare delivery and economic growth
for these people in the right sectors we
can see population begin to level out
otherwise you can see the enormous
problem and that will show up in a few
minutes in another way so that's the
first question the second question is
and I only have a couple more is water
availability when I visited China a year
ago I was taken down to the near the
mouth of the Yellow River Yellow River
was is one of the roughly five major
river systems that were the cradles of
civilizations in the past ten millennia
the Yellow River four months of this
year was dry at the mouth it was all
taken out for agriculture primarily but
other uses as well as climate change
that's occurring in northern China that
is a microcosm
of a general issue of water availability
as populations grow and as needs grow
driven in part by the demand of people
for water and also for changing climate
an issue and the depletion of fossil
resources such as such as our water
under the Ogallala formation in the in
the Midwest that was stored up during
the Pleistocene period and is now being
used up over a period of less than a
hundred years biodiversity loss is
enormous the species are suffering from
invasions of foreign invasives the
habitats are being destroyed
systematically especially in the most
productive of our biological regions the
the tropical forests the gern germ lines
are being depleted and that you can
reflect back on land cover changes where
we see now quickly here since 1900 an
erosion of the amount of forest lands
and the rapid expansion of pasture lands
and crop lands due to peoples expansion
of these uses carefully done I think we
can do ok but if we aren't careful about
what happens to diversity and and
resilience of our biological systems
we're going to be in trouble and if you
look at the species mammal species both
mammals and birds over the period from
about 1600 to now you see that that that
chart is rising very very rapidly and
it's a matter of concern because that's
our biological warehouse of very
interesting molecules and animals as
well as a lot of the joy of living I
think is to live in a very diverse world
and we're in trouble there how much more
trouble we don't know but the 21st
century is going to be the time of most
as we're a moment of truth in that
regard there are things we can do
technologically to assure that we
maintain our existence in a biologically
diverse world but it won't happen
without some careful thought and last I
want to talk a little bit about climate
change because to me it's sort of the
epitome of the issues we face this is a
combination of ice court mostly ice core
data
which relates the global average
temperature and co2 in the Antarctic
over a period of about the last 160,000
years it now goes back about a half a
million years and you see that while
there are very clearly quite significant
differences in these curves that the
gross affects are similar
once one thing one goes up the other is
high when one goes down the other
follows it over the last 160 millennia
if you look more recently and take the
ice core data this is carbon dioxide ice
core data from sorry I don't have these
flaps off from 1600 sorry 1862 the
present ice core data to here and then
measurements directly from the
atmosphere over there incidentally that
was begun in part due to Roger Revelle
and their monitoring that began in
around 1960 at Mont Aloha and in 1960 Al
Gore took a course from Roger Revelle on
resources and environment when these
measurements were just beginning and
Gore who was a political science major
became so excited about this that it was
his transformation and you see how one
lowly professor can affect the future of
some of these politico's anyhow what one
sees here is atmospheric measurements
that show the annual up-and-down due to
the summer versus winter co2
sequestration versus emission during the
wintertime but nonetheless following a
very sharp upward direction now if you
take the take the average temperatures
which are observed and that's the the
the histograms from 1860 to about 1990
and compare them to the models you find
some interesting things one is the green
model is what greenhouse gas additions
alone would do to the average
temperature and you see it sort of falls
behind after about 19
forty or nineteen fifty but then if you
correct for aerosol emissions which goes
along with industrial development and
co2 emissions you find that because
aerosols are warming thing cooling
things whereas greenhouse gases are
warming things one offsets the other and
one has then a chart that would follow
much work directly what we're observing
so what we're observing beginning to
observe our global temperature changes
that are the net result of many things
but primarily of greenhouse gases on the
one hand offset by aerosol particles on
the other leading to an increase now
what concerns me is that you can take
aerosols out of the air pretty fast and
we'd like to for the sake of our lungs
and other things on the other hand you
can't take co2 out very fast it would
take it'll take centuries if not
millennia for that co2 to equivalent
will abate with the oceans where most of
it is stored so that rapid upward rising
is a matter of great concern where does
it take us
it takes us as far as we can tell into
the great unknown of the 21st century
which again is the question are we
leaving ourselves better off off or
worse off in terms of carbon dioxide it
could go doesn't business-as-usual
rapidly upward or we could be careful
about the Ixia - we admit and and begin
to start leveling that off more likely
is this middle curve which is a is a
sharply rising curve taking us on up to
several times pre-industrial co2 by the
end of the next century and the
consequent temperature change while
uncertain is quite significant and moves
us up in the direction that I'll talk to
you in a moment about what its
implications are now again one mark of
the educated person is they can be
emotionally moved by statistics to me
that kind of upward movement on
something that is part of our global
Commons is enough to make me more than a
little bit nervous well if you look a
little bit farther what you might expect
to see we look at u.s. national
precipitation and if you do enough
average
of the observed which are the OA lions
and the end the purple lines to the
light blue which is partly averaged and
then to this sort of line what you find
is is that over the century we have seen
a slight increase in national
precipitation of rain why that's just
what you would expect if you're a
slightly warmer world you're evaporating
more water and that more water gives you
more precipitation but the fact is that
it's not only given you more
precipitation but it's warmer and it
becomes more concentrated in violent
storms and less spread out in light
rains and if you look at the
precipitation index here you find that
first of all we are getting wetter in
parts of the country and drier in others
this is just a a hundred year profile
and this is consistent with the notion
of how you would see changing climate
patterns inside the continent due to
climate change
phenomena but because it's warmer when
it rains it means the ground is warmer
and the water evaporates faster and it
means that therefore paradoxically you
may have more rain but more drought and
this is a drought severity index and you
can see for instance substantial
worsening of drought conditions over the
past in this case about 10 years this is
too short a time to say oh that's global
climate change but it's all data that
that are consistent with the kinds of
things one would expect to see happening
from global climate change another that
finally what one would know not quite
finally next to finally one would expect
to see the increased co2 increase a
certain kind of agricultural
productivity this is part of the good
news and you see that in the northern
hemisphere especially we would expect to
see considerable significant gains in
grain productivity for growth of grains
under the conditions of a doubled carbon
dioxide which is almost assuredly going
to happen even if we work very hard at
levelling things out
the bad news is that further south in
the southern hemisphere it gets worse
not better
and if we want to here we up in New
England and we're I was looking out at
these sugar maples here's what happens
to sugar maples for a doubling of carbon
dioxide in which this is incidentally a
occur showing what happens if you just
increase the temperature but if you're
realistic and change temperature and the
moisture changes that go with it you
find that the current range which is
yellow would move up in this direction
to the blue which would take the
southern extent of the sugar maple on up
to just about the bottom end of Maine
under conditions of a doubled co2 I'm
not sure how happy even West Virginia
would be without sugar maples Chuck but
I think New England would be very
unhappy and with warmer temperature
comes what happens to water when he gets
warmer any answers it expands right okay
you knew that here's what happens with a
1 meter rise in sea level which is a
little over doubling of carbon dioxide
we don't have to worry about much about
the Everglades after that because
they'll be under sea level and those
incursions on coastal areas would be
particularly tough on many of the
third-world countries like Bangladesh in
some of the island states and so it's no
laughing matter that rising sea levels
due to warming oceans can be a very
important phenomenon even in this coming
century and then to reiterate to go back
to the beginning here's what happens in
the right time scale here we are with
the original curve I showed you of of
temperature and carbon dioxide
concentration over the last 150 thousand
years here is the Pleistocene period
this little bump in shelf right here is
the last tenth this is time of
civilization and here's where we are now
in terms of of of co2 concentration
yes yes up here and temperature will
presumably be tracking behind it this
level even at the current level is a
level of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere that we've not seen for many
hundreds of thousands of years and we
are almost undoubtedly committed to a
time of doubling a pre-industrial co2 in
this coming century and we have not seen
that for 50 million years and I don't
think we should be blithely saying well
maybe maybe it'll be okay because I get
nervous about numbers that say we
haven't been there for that long and
we're not quite sure where it's going to
take us so how do we fix it if you look
at how how one could go about getting
off of that business-as-usual curve of
carbon dioxide and moving to limit the
maximum ultimate concentration of co2 to
perhaps double pre-industrial co2
although I think it'll probably go
beyond that you see that a minimum cost
path to get there in terms of
overhauling our our industrial systems
and replacing our capital stock at a
reasonable rate will take us some time
it'll even have to increase before it
decreases we simply can't move that fast
without making too much economic
hardship but you will note that it needs
to peak up and start coming back down
again even by about the year 2040 or
2050 so we don't have that much time if
we hope to hold anywhere near a doubling
of pre-industrial co2 that's not much
time and I that brings us to Kyoto and
I'll talk in future talks about some of
the machination 'z that went on with
respect to Kyoto but you recall in Kyoto
the issue was can we level out our rates
of emission of co2 from the US and other
countries to the present level of
emissions the present level of emissions
would carry us on up well beyond this
they would continue to load into the
atmosphere in terms of concentration
because it doesn't come back
the atmosphere so what we're talking
about is not even getting off the orange
line in order to follow along the Kyoto
Protocol so let's have a lesson very
briefly in some simple arithmetic the
car the current carbon emissions as I
showed you that green curve are about 6
billion tons a year that's about one ton
per person globally right the u.s. is
about five times that about five tons
per person per year the third world is
around a half a ton per person per year
but one-tenth of ours you can see why
they say it's our problem not not theirs
the least cost per trajectory that I
showed you just a moment ago would take
it that would take us to about 550 parts
per million concentration in the long
term implies by the time we get to the
year 2100 we should that we should still
be at about 6 Giga tons of carbon per
year about the same amount we're
producing now and that means with
population growth about six tenths of a
ton per person per year instead of one
ton now now if you assume a two percent
growth rate which some economists would
say that's in tolerably low now that
means a factor of about eight in a
hundred years in terms of resource
consumption and if you don't change them
on a carbon a per per energy produced to
make that kind of growth then the
allowable amount of carbon per person
per year becomes less than one-tenth of
a ton per person per year
well that compared to five tons per year
which we're trying to hold to now means
that we have to essentially move from a
relatively high number and not just
stabilize it as we would for Kyoto but
essentially wipe it entirely out in the
course of a hundred years that's the
simple arithmetic if we choose not to do
that then the later generations will
suffer on account of it the extent to
which we can achieve that means that
we're taking the load off of future
generations
well to remind you the u.s. is
one-fourth of all of the action in terms
of the co2 that's up in the atmosphere I
understand exactly why the third world
says you folks ought to lead because you
got a sir to start with but if you look
a little bit ahead in the 21st century
you find that by the year 2035 the
developing countries in terms of
emissions will equal and then begin to
exceed those of all the industrial
nations they understand this the chinese
full understand that they're going to be
in the same boat as us in terms of
emissions and responsibilities here
within the next several decades but
don't forget where we're coming from
we're coming from totally dominated
being totally dominated by the
developing nations and what about our
energy it's very simple about one third
each and buildings industry and
transportation I talked about
transportation a while ago there was a
recent analysis of rather draconian
analysis about what we might have to do
to level out our emissions and one
number which is from a patently
pessimistic study by the Energy
Information Administration it says we
might have to add as much as 60 cents a
gallon on our gasoline over the next
decade or so here's the price of
gasoline in the 90s and if you add 60
cents to u.s. gasoline and we never I'm
sure we'd never have to do anything like
that but if we did it would take us out
to about here and we would be maybe in
up to Canada in terms of what we're
charging for gasoline still far far far
behind all the rest of the industrial
countries sacrifice yes but how big over
10 years I'm not sure we endured nearly
a tripling of prices in the 70s and grew
right through the whole period so let me
now wind up very quickly I think we have
a lot of attractive options there are a
lot of cost factors time is needed
because much of this requires that
turnover of capital stock and its
replacement by
improved capital stock we need to have
international trading and emissions of
carbon and we need to have offsets for
instance a recent resources for the
future study shows that probably a good
30% of all the costs of doing this are
direct savings from other pollution
costs which would drop on account of
this so you could offset probably a
third of it
for that alone and I think there are a
lot of of other instabilities and
concerns we ought to be thinking about
while we try to make our way toward
doing what we can for having a global
climate system that is a little bit less
moving into the unknown that it is right
now we know many of you have heard of
the issue of potential instability of
ocean currents especially the North
Atlantic other instabilities such as the
positive feedback that could come from
the melting of methane clathrates and
the in the oceans the recent break off
of another 50 square miles of the Larson
was it 50 of the of the Larsen Ice Shelf
in the Antarctic another example of
changes in ocean currents and other
positive feedbacks as Harvey Brooks said
some years back it's probably not those
things we know about that we should be
really worried that much about it's
those things that we haven't even
thought about yet that we probably are
going to have to worry more about and
I'll just give you an example here to me
a shocker if you look at the amount of
nitrogen fixed in the whole planet it's
about this much for I think there's
terra grams per year from all natural
sources lightening bacterial fixation
all these other processes here's what's
happened just to anthropogenic nitrogen
fixing since the turn of the century
we've gone from a small fraction of
natural nitrogen fixing to the point now
that where we substantially exceed all
of the so-called natural sources of
nitrogen fixing on the whole planet now
what does this mean
I'm not sure what it means except it
tells me again that human active
are beginning to dominate some of our
global parameters and that the 21st
century is going to have to be a moment
of truth for us to at least understand
these things better if not try to do
something about them and where does that
take me it takes me all the way back to
to a rather strategic statement that was
developed I think originally by John
Holdren and Paul Ehrlich namely that if
you talk about an insult pollution let's
call it and and and break it up into two
identities then you can talk about how
you can tackle it we can talk we can
break up pollution into pollution per
unit of energy produced x amount of
energy per GNP produced times GNP per
population unit times population a very
simple mathematically incorrect but
helpful strategic approach to thinking
about things what we've talked about
today is the use of technology to reduce
the amount of pollution per unit of
energy or goods produced with with
efficiency we've talked about Market
Basket changes in terms of energy
required to produce a unit of GNP again
using technology we've talked a little
bit about GNP per population but we hope
GNP however defined by new market
baskets is going to be able to continue
to grow and then ultimately there's a
population factor technology in
particular is is extremely important for
these first two terms and is ultimately
relatable to the ease with which we can
introduce five effective family-planning
to people so across the board technology
in terms of its challenge to either help
provide for for people or to give us
problems in the 21st century is is all
the way across the board and of course
these are things that politicians want
to jump on right away right I don't know
whether you can read this but so I
better read it to you he says our son is
more than four billion years old and
it's already reached about half its life
expectancy it's now time to plan for the
future mankind and a positive first step
is the election of someone who's willing
to face this vital problem I think we're
gonna face that problem not with respect
to the Sun but with respect to some of
these other things that are very much on
our plate for the 21st century
now our bottom line I think is as I said
I think we have plenty of opportunities
to take things either way we all of
society has that choice but science and
technology has a very special role in
that process in providing the means to
understand what's happening and the
options to do something about it in a
productive way and I think our measure
will be our commitment our investment in
research and development in innovation
in the transformation of production and
energy and in our orientation toward
preventive measures whether it be in
health or in waste or in deadly conflict
second I think a measure is our
responsiveness to global climate change
challenges a conservative response we
hope as if the future really mattered
for us a proactive link to other
environmental and resource challenges so
that we get two for one and doing it
undertaking it soon enough that we can
pace our way toward the future
third attention to the conservation of
living capital our so called natural
wealth of the planet which may be at
least if not more important than all of
our invented wealth that means
biodiversity habitat protection germ
plasm and species protection fourth our
outreach to the developing world our
leadership by example in terms of
stabilizing our population and our use
of in our consumption of resources our
ability to help them understand the
value if not the advantage of taking
alternative growth paths fifth and
finally I think the new attention to
intergenerational equity new measures
for growth and progress not how much raw
resource raw materials we consume every
year devising some sustainable futures
that is a sense of dynamic equilibrium
that can substitute for exponentiation
as a measure of how well we're doing and
where we're growing and that's a whole
new way of thinking about
how you grow do you grow through
Exponential's where efficiency simply
postpones the time in which you run into
trouble again or do you think in terms
of some movement to a dynamic situation
or changes in efficiency in the likes
have lasting importance they act more
like an endowment and and ultimately I
think we have to think it has to come
back home we have to connect local to
global actions I love Gary Larson
sometimes and you see here the logger
has is forgetting as he describes how
this tree so miraculously survived those
millennia of time he's forgetting the
fact that he just chopped it down
himself and of course you have to close
with Lucy and peanuts about are we gonna
help or hurt the next generation I would
hope that our answer is not that we will
stick the next generation but that we
will use the the talents that we have
the opportunities we have which are
glorious and manifold to leave the place
a little better battle for our our
great-grandchildren and then then
perhaps it was left for us and I want to
thank you for your patience this
afternoon that's the end of lecture
number one thank you
oh I'll take a few questions and I also
want to remind you that that if you grow
tired of questions our hosts have
provided us with some wonderful food and
drink outside as soon as we leave the
auditorium but I'll stay for a little
bit if you want yes
based on your experience in government
the point did you hear the point raised
was that that this is indeed a global
issue and therefore and my optimistic or
pessimistic given say the Kyoto
convention of about whether we can make
it or not
I think our I'm not sure how it's going
to come out but we can ill afford to
assume that we that we aren't going to
make it and it seems to me the the thing
incumbent on the intellectual capital we
have and to our inventiveness and
technology is to show how we can provide
for this in a way that has a net win
result for everybody if you take into
account future generations I can't help
but remain an optimist even though I've
gotten bloodied up a bit here and there
I do believe that the Kyoto was
certainly no magical success but it did
put some things on the table that are
now a matter of global discussion and
the the informal discussions are much
more encouraging than the official
actions and that's what you always
expect but I think given the given the
extraordinary success of the Montreal
Protocol and the and the the
stratospheric ozone as an example gives
me still hope that we we have we will
have an ability to do it meanwhile we've
got to really try to harden and firm up
our scientific understanding of what's
going on we've got to work very hard
consistently to develop technologies
that enable us to go to less
carbon-intensive 'no sand other things
so that we can get there even even more
profitably or less a less of a loss and
we have to lay those things in place so
that we can provide options if you have
options then it's an easier political
decision to be made and I think everyone
needs to understand it is a Commons and
everyone's anyone's win is everyone's
win in this business
well it's kind of hard for me because I
tried it twice once when I worked for
Nixon and I got John Saul Hill to
propose a gasoline tax and Nixon fired
him a week later and in this
administration I've worked with mr.
Clinton and we proposed an 18 cent a
gallon tax and the Congress worked hard
for us and got four cents very hard
there's a kind of romance with making
and keeping gasoline cheaper than than
bottled water and I'm honestly a despair
on this but I can't help but feel that
if people could be presented with a
sensible package in which revenues from
raising taxes on gasoline as they do in
all the other industrial countries and
let letting that displace other taxes
that are far less far more regressive is
a net win for people but it has to be
presented in an integrated package in
order to sell it and that's a that's a
real job for us yeah
yes Americans are less concerned I think
because we're in a sense more insular we
we don't quite have the press that some
of the European countries have
especially those along the coast like
the Netherlands and it's a lot harder
for us you know Germany all they have to
do is fix East Germany and they've got
all the gains to succeed in for Kyoto
all the English have to do is keep
moving toward natural gas and that'll
fix them up automatically so there are a
lot of political games being played in
that Europe and France of course has a
very large nuclear capacity they're 80
percent nuclear so they are playing some
political games they understand it's
more difficult for us but that's the
reality of politics and our negotiations
in in Kyoto were to try to get across
the fact that we have a bigger problem
because a we've been growing a lot fast
we've been really growing since 1990 and
Europe has been almost retreating during
that same period so we're already
generating a lot more co2 simply because
of economic expansion and I think the
understanding of this is going to come
about as we continue the dialogue about
what is a meaningful implementation and
finally we've done our homework more I
think than most of Europe as we
understand the dynamics of trying to
level out carbon dioxide production and
some of the other countries have not
that have not done that much analytical
work their statements have been more on
on political grounds
well you know some of the people on the
mainland of Europe say that as soon as
you cross the channel you get into
trouble because because the engineers
are no longer really that much a part of
the parliaments and the likes it is
amazing to see the change sure yeah
that's right that's right and it's big
help the what I say is that I think it
can be done whether it will be done
depends a lot on how well members of our
community work with the non-technical
elected officials of our nation and work
with them much more effectively to help
them come to a better understanding of
where we are and also for us to work
with the American people because if
people can be easily misled by the
winsome songs of special interests then
they're not going to be motivated to do
something and it's well it's more
cooperative in Germany there's no doubt
about it and they're green technology
and the likes they're green industry is
moving a lot faster than their own and
we have much to learn from the Germans
in that regard
it is a different culture and I'm not
saying it's easy but I'm saying there
are there opportunities here and there
under attendant in that I think our
community of Science and Technology has
not been as as extensively integrated
into the national political debates as
it needs to be and I want to praise
Chuck vest for his engagement with the
university community even just in trying
to get the research budgets maintained
and held on to because we had a lot of
problems there the the majority let's
see the the whip of the house some
months ago I guess about a year ago now
said one day that he wanted to get rid
of all the NOAA satellites weather
satellites because he said we've got the
television weather stations why do we
need those satellites he didn't even
understand the connectivity between
those two things and those are the folks
we have to work with I think Chuck got
to him within 24 hours but but it's when
I tried to point out today is I think
there's an existence theorem and there
are a few examples of where we have made
connections and I think the challenge in
the 21st century is not only to reach
these people more effectively but also
push those frontiers of options and push
those frontiers of understanding so that
we have a harder case to make and a more
easily accepted case because we found
some some excellent tech fixes to help
make it work with minimum pain and
discomfort pretty well
[Music]
Boston has a rich history I think I
think there was a County Courthouse to
it rich history in this regard I don't
want to comment on Boston's rich history
but I do I do remember something bout a
courthouse that just kept absorbing
money did it ever get finished and then
well I see we've made some progress then
no III you know there's gonna be waste
if you look at this half trillion dollar
budget that was just passed there's a
lot of nonsense in there too and we have
to we have to contend with that and
remember that policy decisions are
processes if we make some mistakes this
year let's go back and get them fixed
next year but keep moving it in the
right direction and don't be discouraged
because because it is a for-real process
but I don't know of anything that would
work better
I remember Thomas Jefferson once said
that no man's house or hearth is no
man's home or hearth our safe when the
legislature is in session and I think
that always has been the case and
probably always will be yes if you look
at the dense ice the cores down in these
these ice fields of Antarctica and to a
certain degree Greenland you find a
beautiful written record if you know how
to read it and reading the record means
you have to have elegant chemical and
physical methods to look at the tiny
little bubbles of air that are inside
the ice and to measure the isotopic
ratio of oxygen 16 and oxygen 18 which
leads you back to a temperature and the
and the measurement actually of methane
and co2 in these tiny bubbles and it's
extraordinary because there's a
consistent and well proven method now
for tracing our way back in time to
those those very very long early
conditions which in turn tell us so much
about what the net dynamics were and
where we are now right now that
moment they're looking at similar cords
that are giving us extraordinary detail
about the last 10,000 years and what
happened in the North Atlantic that in
turn affected European weather in our
own and that shows the enormous value of
investing in fundamental science to
understand better who we are what it is
we what it is what the earth is like and
how it's behaved in the past but it came
from from I scored well you going back
before that 150,000 years and find other
bumps and dips and and changes but it
tells you that what his past may also be
what is prologue except now what is
happening is that we are things are
changing faster than anything in the
last 50 million years probably and
that's why I called it because it copied
someone else who used the phrase it's a
human bolide or asteroid that is now
smacking the earth in a way that is
transforming over the course of a couple
of centuries transforming the earth in
terms of its atmosphere its biodiversity
all sorts of other things we know that
one hit of 76 million years ago except
it wasn't asteroid a couple miles in
diameter and and that got our attention
because it happened all of a sudden
called the KT boundary what's happening
now is happening geologically all of a
sudden over several hundred years but
it's us not some heavenly body the 170
million years ago was those bumps in the
past had to do with orbital variations
orbital changes of the earth which
happen every let's see what is it
I forget the Russians name about every
150 thousand years who is it
the Milankovitch is cycle there are
several astronomical cycles that we go
through there are other things that
happened volcanism other things that can
change the atmosphere and in turn change
the change the radiative balance and
happy to talk with you more about it
later and if I don't know Mario will so
yes one of the more interesting articles
I'm not a specialist in this area but
one of the most interesting articles I
read different ways to achieve been
talking about was in the New York Times
awhile ago and it was talking about how
the fuel efficiency guidelines and I
don't know whether this was in the cafe
so-called cafe regulations for the
vehicle fleet so-called for the United
States had been set in a certain way but
that the sport league so-called sport
utility vehicles SUVs that are so much
in evidence had been classified as not
as trucks but as cars or as an in
another category so they were exempt and
that games that were being made in
certain areas were being offset by the
growing use and it was growing sale of
these sport utility vehicles that's
right yeah this to me is it it's a very
interesting and instructive case study
in the political dimension as it relates
to the technology seems like there's
lots of good information there
there are a lot there's a pretty good
understanding of some of the
technological issues it's a pretty good
understanding of fuel emissions and
pollution what there seems to be missing
is the political will to implement the
wisdom and you talk about that a little
but it seems to me that that warrants
you know as much as the issue is about
technology if it certainly warrants I
mean it may be the crux of the matter
it seems to me I'm sets us up for the
next lecture but you're right and that
that that categorization of of light
trucks and their special treatment on
Cafe was a masterful stroke on the part
of Detroit I think and it is costing us
now in terms of our missions and I must
say there are other gains being made
efficiency of engines and the likes
which could roll into efficiency but
instead of rolling into horsepower so
you find the enormous horsepower still
with vehicles getting 2025 miles per
gallon if they drop their horsepower
anything like they were back in the late
seventies we would be up around 35 or
more miles per gallon already so those
games are gonna be played and what our
job to do is to try to see what case
should be made to say that we it is in
our self-interest to start trading power
for efficiency in these areas in terms
of variety of national opportunities for
lower import requirements less dependent
on Middle Eastern oil less air pollution
in our cities in the life and that's a
job that we must be a part of in
informing the public and helping inform
that debate what interests would you say
are driving to what you call it Detroit
I mean major automobile what did what
are the interests that are driving there
up is there their construction of those
kinds of loopholes well one thing the
SUV's are the most profitable of all of
the lines from Detroit and they've been
able to sell them on on a lot of imagery
as well as a lot of very functional
utility to people but you notice most of
those ads have these things climbing up
wilderness trails and the likes and not
probably one in a hundred will do it
it's an imagery thing it's sort of like
mall burrows I used to smoke mall births
you know the old cowboy but marketing is
a very powerful tool and the private
sector knows how to use it very well
with and these are extreme this is the
most profitable line that Detroit makes
are the sport utility vehicles mr. Sloan
also I believe said that sell
automobiles by the pound if he had more
pounds to him they sell for a higher
price and that's more profits so making
heavy vehicles like some of these
extraordinary things I've forgotten the
name of Alpine know that Alaskan Yukon
or any how some of those things weigh
four or five thousand pounds and use
them to go down and pick up groceries
so we have an image problem here at the
same time Detroit has been working hard
I must say on some of the advanced
concepts for fuel cells for hybrid
direct injection diesel four-stroke
diesels a lot of other very advanced
technologies and my hope is ultimately
not whether we win the game this year
but whether we can put in place over the
next several years the kinds of
technologies that will give the option
in the first decade in the next century
to really transform our transportation
system so that it can in fact help move
us in the right direction that we're
gonna have to move in the 21st century
yeah
the question is if we did all this in
terms of our development how I should we
be asking the third world to slow down
and not do it in their development my
answer to this is that for instance if
you go to China today you won't find
anybody putting up telephone lines
they're all using mobile phones
cellular phones they are bypassing some
of the ways we did in our development
because it's better it's cheaper and
it's more effective and you can go all
the way through the economy and say if
we don't just track along what those
folks did 50 years ago but we leapfrog
over some of those bad technologies and
pick up the best then we'll move in a
new way of development and the new way
of development is far less demanding on
resources and on energy and makes far
less carbon dioxide it's going as as
Vice President Gore says it's going the
smart way of someone said I think it's
tiny statement that the wise person
learns from experience the wiser person
learns from someone else's experience
yes
can't quite hear drug resistance
microbes are a big problem and they are
engendered by inattentive use by the by
the medical profession of antibiotics in
many countries you can simply buy
antibiotics over-the-counter and in many
instances here a doctor will prescribe
when they're rotten not really needed
and by the absolutely indiscriminate use
of antibiotics in animal feeds as a way
of cutting debt of increasing slightly
they're they're a well being especially
if they aren't that well cared for and
that provides a subclinical level of
antibiotic which is perfect for killing
only the weak germs but enabling the
stronger germs to evolve and and and
develop recent Academy of Sciences a
publication on this is affirms what OTA
said about a decade ago namely our use
of Hanabi our misuse of antibiotics is
providing the breeding ground for the
new lethal pathogens that will follow
the second thing that happens is that as
you go in and disturb systems whether it
be the clearing of a tropical forest or
the onset of a rainfall and a
traditionally dry area then you find
pathogens that were once confined to
that area
breaking out has happened I think with
Ebola has happened with cholera in in
South America has happened with the
hantavirus in the southwest and so these
are various ways these pathogens can
develop and I dare say it's more serious
of a problem than some some terrorists a
bacteriologist doing doing his or her
thing and it is a matter of concern
there is a new so-called emerging and
infectious diseases activity at the
Centers for Disease Control tied to the
World Health Organization now creating
an international network of warning and
alerting of the emergence of new paths
that we think is going to help because
the pathogen can move now because of
modern transportation from one end of
the world to the other before they even
begin to manifest themselves in in their
hoe in the in the condition of their
host I think it's a matter of great
concern and I I would hope that we well
I almost hope that my grandchildren are
going to go into medicine because these
bugs mutate faster than we can create
doctors to cure them and I think we if
we now know for instance we only have
one or two antibiotics for some of the
more resistant strains of several of the
common pathogens so the war on
infectious disease is not over it's
going to be a continuing struggle and
it's being exacerbated by other human
activities want to understand risk
benefit analysis
as an observer of a public media which
seems to have no real ability to make
judgments about relative risk and
promising examples well I would hope an
example and maybe I should talk about
this next time of of Dolly the cloning
of Dolly and the use of an adult
mammalian cell to create a clone and the
treatment of that situation by the
president the very very carefully worded
statement he made which surrounded the
issue and fenced off research from being
locked up by the Congress was a good
example of where we try to get the
public informed about just what this is
and what it is not and therefore what
should be could the concern of the
community in terms of the social
constraints on these technologies and
the creation by the president of the
National bio ethics Advisory Commission
was very helpful in that regard so I
think there are hopeful ways but it
takes a lot of work and without an OTA
around it's it's much more difficult I
would hope that the various things going
on here right at MIT can be helpful in
that regard because you have a lot of
interdepartmental interdisciplinary
programs that are focusing some very
powerful and and and diverse
capabilities on these problems and I
think that kind of thoughtful work
especially if if carefully moved to the
market place of the policy makers can be
very very helpful in the future and I
think I think the universities like MIT
may have to become a distributed set of
OTAs around the country in the in the
coming several years yeah
I already is their most important
parameter there requires immediate
attention well it's hard to sort them up
because they're important for different
reasons
I would I would venture that perhaps the
most important thing for us in the
coming several years is to spend a lot
of time and attention on trying to help
in any way we can to help Russia get
through the narrows in that and in our
link there is one of our strongest links
is in between our scientific communities
the same with China in getting through
their narrows of moving toward a market
economy but in their own their own form
of government because their government
is mostly engineers and I think those
are two countries that if we had to
concentrate on places that if we work
hard now the benefits are going to be
enormous it's going to be the equivalent
at the Millennium of what what the
Marshall Plan did at the end of the
Second World War I should think that
would be to me thinking out loud a very
important way to move and it's a special
role for technology in science because
with those people in China and Russia we
have special relationships that we
should capitalize on well thank you very
much there's a refreshments downstairs
thank you